feu d'artifice annulé à Chelles en
Seine-et-Marne même chose à
Aulnay-sous-Bois en Seine-Saint-Denis
les festivités dans leur grande majorité
sont maintenues il y a très peu de
communes qui ont renoncé à organiser ces
festivités et comme le ministre de
l'Intérieur l'a rappelé hier il y a pas
d'instruction du gouvernement ces
annonces se multiplient et pas qu'en
Île-de-France Montargis Strasbourg ou
Roubaix renonce aussi à leur festivités
c'est une fête
que nul
ne doit pouvoir gâcher sous quelques
prétextes que ce soit au Blanc-Mesnil en
banlieue de Paris il n'y aura pas de feu
d'artifice et pas de plage éphémères non
plus les économies réalisées permettront
ainsi de financer les réparations
nécessaires après les émeutes
certains
souhaitaient gâcher la fête
je veux dire ici de façon solennelle
claire
que la justice sera au rendez-vous ces
gens qui malheureusement ne pourront pas
bénéficier de l'opération plage éphémère
et qui n'en sont pour rien dans les
émeutes peut-être qu'ils vont prendre en
main ces jeunes et qui vont leur dire
écouter les gamins ça suffit maintenant
parce que vos conneries on en pâtit tous
pour chaque 14 juillet il y a un peu
plus de violences urbaines que
d'habitude ça fait partie des traditions
il y a toujours des de des violences
urbaines toujours contenu toujours
limitées
et le Ren et le rendez-vous
en fait national pour une fête nationale
qui est supposée être et qui est la fête
d'une communion nationale d'une nation
voilà ce qu'il a fait de la France un
pays dans lequel on ne peut même plus
célébrer le 14 juillet parce qu'on a
peur on s'habituera jamais à ce que ces
moments soient des moments de
débordement ou des moments d'expression
de violence quel que soit leur forme ça
n'est pas normal ça n'a pas sa place en
République et c'est pour cela que nous
nous mobilisons
ces émeutes sont le symptôme
spectaculaires d'un mal beaucoup plus
profond qui touche notre pays la
désintégration de l'État et de la nation
dans l'intérêt de la nation Laurent
Wauquiez propose une union sacrée autour
de mesures fortes expulsion des
étrangers chocs carcéral suspension des
aides sociales autour des mesures qu'il
propose vous dites quoi ok moi je dis
que l'union sacrée elle doit être pour
la France elle doit être pour les
Français elle doit être pour faire des
progrès j'ai pas le sentiment que
Laurent Wauquiez et une plateforme de
progrès Laurent Wauquiez souhaite
également servir sur le plan financier
il faut enfin restaurer une idée de
devoir face au droit aux suspendant
comme le propose erikiotti les aides
sociales au délinquants et parents de
délinquants les parents des émeutiers
doivent-ils payer pour les dégâts causés
par leurs enfants lors des dernières
violences urbaines et par conséquent
faut-il leur supprimer les aides
sociales c'est l'objet de notre dernier
sondage cnews
73% des Français sont pour la
suppression des aides sociales pour les
familles des émeutiers
dans le détail les sympathisants de
droite sont majoritairement pour en fait
pendant longtemps on évoquait des crises
qui s'enchaînaient et aujourd'hui les
crises ont tendance à s'empiler et entre
la crise sanitaire la guerre en Ukraine
vivrait avec l'inflation
en fait les personnes les plus fragiles
ce sont encore fragilisés et c'est
encore plus vulnérables toujours aucune
nouvelle du petit Emile deux ans et demi
disparu samedi au Vernet dans les Alpes
de Haute-Provence après avoir échappé à
la vigilance de ses grands-parents les
opérations de ratissage devaient
s'achever ce matin
le fait alors rythmique plein de gens
qui considèrent que la terre est plate
c'est oui je veux je pense que
aujourd'hui on m'en manque un peu de
cadre on manque un peu de
on cherche quelque chose à quoi se
raccrocher il y a une forme de lâcheté
de déni qui existe depuis 20 ans 30 ans
et que aujourd'hui il faut se réveiller
c'est pas en hystérisant le débat qu'on
va se réveiller mais en parlant vrai et
grosse frayeur faut les passagers
à maîtriser un homme armé d'un couteau
après une bagarre au cours de laquelle
un coup de feu a été tiré sans faire de
blesser soyez fier de votre métier soyez
fier de ce que vous faites les Français
vous aiment votre Ministre vous aime et
je crois que tous les élus qui sont ici
quelques sera mort politique vous aime